IT.
JOHN, THANKS SO MUCH.
GREAT REPORTING.
GET SOME SLEEP.
WHAT SHOULDN'T BE LOST ON YOU
IS, ANY OF THE VIEWERS, THAT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S ORIGINAL
MANDATE WAS TO FIND OUT WHAT
RUSSIA DO TO INFLUENCE THE 2016
ELECTION.
TODAY THERE IS STUFF AND NO
EVIDENCE PRESENTED BY THE
MUELLER TEAM THAT ANY CRIMINAL
COLLUSION OCCURRED BETWEEN TRUMP
FOLKS AND THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT.
SO PERHAPS WE CAN BREATHE A
LITTLE BIT BEFORE YOU MAKE ANY
GRAND DECLARATIONS ABOUT WHERE
THE INVESTIGATION IS GOING.
FOR MORE INSIGHT, WE PUT
TOGETHER EXPERTS WHO CAN PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE ANSWERS.
SOL WISENBERG, FORMER DEPUTY
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL DURING
WHITEWATER.
JAME TRUSTEE, FORMER DOJ
ATTORNEY.
HERE WITH ME IN STUDIO, HOUSE
INTEL MEMBER MICHAEL TURNER AND
JOHN SOLOMON, INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER AND CONTRIBUTOR ON THE
HILL.
CONGRESSMAN, WHERE WE ARE RIGHT
NOW SEEMS LIKE LEAPS AND BOUNDS
BEYOND WHAT WE WERE LED TO
BELIEVE WHEN THIS ENTIRE THING
KICKED OFF WHEN JEFF SESSIONS
REFUSES, ROSENSTEIN STEPPED IN.
SEEMS TO HAVE A REAL MELTDOWN,
DECIDES GOT TO APPOINT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL, AND HERE WE ALL ALL
THIS TIME LATER WITH A
72-YEAR-OLD GUY, LOOKS LIKE HE
MIGHT GET CHARGED WITH
SOMETHING.
ROGER STONE KICKING AROUND.
NOW WE HAVE THIS DEAL WITH
MICHAEL COHEN.
>> YOU HAVE AN EXCELLENT POINT
ABOUT WHAT THE ORIGINAL MANDATE
WAS FOR THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
WHEN THE NEWS FIRST BROKE,
LOOKED LIKE HE WAS AN EXCITING
STORY ABOUT MICHAEL COHEN ANAND
COMING FORWARD WITH A GUILTY
PLEA ABOUT LYING.
UPON FURTHER INVESTIGATION,
WHAT'S NOTABLE IS THAT IN THE
WRITTEN STATEMENT HE GAVE TO THE
SENATE, HE MADE A STATEMENT THAT
HE WAS NOT INVOLVED IN COLLUSION
WITH RUSSIA, THE RUSSIAN
FEDERATION.
NOT INVOLVED IN ANY WAY IN ANY
HACKING.
THIS IS NOT A STATEMENT HE PLED
GUILTY TO TODAY OR THAT THE
MUELLER TEAM ALLEGED WAS FALSE.
YOU HAVE A STATEMENT THAT
RELATES TO THE MANDATE OF THE
INVESTIGATION THAT'S NOT THE
SUBJECT MATTER OF AN ALLEGED LIE
AT THIS POINT.
YOU HAVE THE INVESTIGATION AND
THE MARCHING OF THE GUILTY PLEA
OVER A FAILED REAL ESTATE DEAL,
NOT THE SAME THING.
NOT WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
IF THE SPECIAL COUNSEL AND
INFORMATION THAT THIS WAS A
FALSE STATEMENT FROM MICHAEL
COHEN, YOU WOULD'VE EXPECTED
THAT WOULD'VE BEEN PART OF THE
GUILTY PLEA TODAY.
>> Laura: SAUL, THE FALSE
STATEMENT, IT'S A CLASSIC GO TO
CHARGE IN THESE TYPES OF CASES.
DON'T TELL LIES TO A PROSECUTOR.
YOU GET BIG TROUBLE WHEN YOU DO.
BUT IT'S ALSO A TOOL, THE CYNICS
WOULD SAY, PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO
BE IN JAIL FOR THE NEXT 60 YEARS
AND YOU GET YOUR SENTENCE
REDUCED IF MAY BE, I GUESS IT
WASN'T COMPLETELY FORTHCOMING.
HOW DO YOU SEE IT TODAY FITTING
INTO THE OVERALL NARRATIVE?
>> IF YOU ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE
PLEA AGREEMENT AND THAT THE
CRIMINAL INFORMATION, THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING THAT
IMPLICATES PRESIDENT TRUMP IN A
CRIME.
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NOTHING IN
THERE THAT SAYS WHERE MICHAEL
COHEN SAYS PRESIDENT TRUMP
TALKED WITH ME ABOUT THE LIE I
WAS GOING TO DELTA CONGRESS.
WE CONSPIRED.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT.
THERE IS NOTHING WHATSOEVER.
WE CONFINE OURSELVES TO THE
ACTUAL LAW AND NOT A BUNCH OF
BABBLE YOU HERE ALL DAY ON
TELEVISION.
LET'S JUST LOOK AT THE ACTUAL
DOCUMENTS.
IT DOESN'T IMPLICATE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN ANY WAY WHICH
BRINGS UP THE QUESTION OF WHY HE
WAS SO ANGRY IF HE HAD BEEN TOLD
ABOUT THIS AND WHY HE CAME OUT
AND SAID COHEN IS NOTHING BUT A
LIAR.
HE'S LYING.
ALL COHEN SAID WAS I LIED TO
CONGRESS.
HE DIDN'T SAY PRESIDENT TRUMP
HELPED ME LIVE.
THERE COULD BE ALL KINDS OF
THINGS THAT MUELLER IS KEEPING
QUIET FROM US THAT WE DON'T KNOW
ABOUT.
THAT COHEN HAS TOLD HIM.
THAT'S POSSIBLE.
BUT THAT'S THE REALM OF
SPECULATION.
LET'S TALK ABOUT REALITY, AND
REALITY IS THIS IS A NOTHING
BURGER.
>> Laura: JOHN SOLOMON, TO
LISTEN TO CONGRESSMAN ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE TODAY,
ERIC SWALWELL, ONE OF OUR
FAVORITES COME I WANT YOU TO
LISTEN TO WHAT HE SAID ABOUT
WHERE THIS IS ALL GOING.
>> I BELIEVE THEY ARE
OBSTRUCTING THE COLLISION AND
AGAIN THIS IS WHERE DONALD TRUMP
WILL SAY THEY ARE TRYING TO RING
HIM UP ON LIES.
ONLY GUILTY PEOPLE LIE IN WHAT
THEY ARE TRYING TO PROTECT IS
THAT THE PRESIDENT, HIS FAMILY,
BUSINESSES AND CAMPAIGN SOUGHT
DIRT ON HILLARY CLINTON FROM THE
RUSSIANS AND SOUGHT TO DO A BIG
DEAL IN MOSCOW AT THE TIME OF
THE CAMPAIGN.
WHEN THEY WERE CONFRONTED ABOUT
IT, THEY LIED.
WHERE I COME FROM, THAT'S
COLLUSION.
>> Laura: JOHN.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHERE HE COMES
FROM BUT IT ISN'T COLLUSION.
TODAY THE PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY
ADMITTED TO LYING ABOUT A
BUSINESS DEAL THAT WOULD'VE BEEN
PERFECTLY LEGAL, MAY BE STUPID
BUT PERFECTLY LEGAL IF IT WENT
THROUGH.
HE DOESN'T IMPLICATE THE
PRESIDENT AT ALL.
AND I THINK MORE BROADLY, PEOPLE
ARE MISSING THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
WHY THIS HAPPENED TODAY.
BOB MUELLER WAITED IN WAIT TO
SEE WITH THE PRESIDENT WOULD SAY
IT IS ANSWERS TO SEE IF HE COULD
CATCH HIM IN A PERJURY TRAP.
THE PRESIDENT ANSWERED
CONSISTENT WITH THE EVIDENCE, SO
NOW HE'S CLEANING UP THE COHEN
INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: JAMES, HOW WOULD YOU
AS A PROSECUTOR IN THE CRIMINAL
DIVISION TREAT A WITNESS LIKE
COHEN WHO'S OBVIOUSLY -- HE WAS
TRADING ON THE PRESIDENT'S NAME.
HE STRIKES ME AS SOMEONE WHO
LOVED BEING CLOSE TO POWER AND
HE KNEW TRUMP, OBVIOUSLY.
HELPED HIM, AS THE PRESIDENT
SAID, ON A   A BIG FAVOR YEARS A
SAID, ON A   A BIG FAVOR YEARS O
SAID, ON A   A BIG FAVOR YEARS .
HOW DO YOU TREAT HIM GIVEN HIS
ADMITTED SLIPPERINESS WITH THE
TRUTH AND FACTS?
>> LOOK, YOU HAVE TO GO INTO IT
KNOWING YOUR KIND OF ENGAGING IN
SNAKE WRESTLING.
AS THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY, I WOULD
RELISH THE IDEA OF
CROSS-EXAMINING THIS GUY.
HE'S A LAWYER WHO BETRAYED HIS
CLIENT.
SAID HE WOULD TOOK A BULLET,
DIDN'T BELIEVE IT.
HE ADMITS HIS OWN CULPABILITY
AND NOW HE'S TRYING TO GET A
BREAK FROM THE JUDGE.
THERE'S A MILLION THINGS YOU
COULD CROSS-EXAMINE ON BUT I
HAVE TO SAY SOME OF THE
PROSECUTORS ON THAT TEAM KNOW
THEIR WAY AROUND THE COURTHOUSE.
GREG WOULD PUT MOBSTERS ON THE
STAND WHEN A LOT OF BAGGAGE.
THEY ARE NOT BLIND TO THE FACT
THAT THIS GUY IS KIND OF A
HORRIBLE CHARACTER ARE NOT
INSTANTLY LIKABLE BY MANY
OUTSIDE HIS FAMILY.
>> Laura: WE HAVE FORGOTTEN
HIS TAPE RECORDINGS.
HE HAS TAPE RECORDINGS
APPARENTLY.
>> THAT'S THE THING.
IF HE HAS DOCUMENTS, EMAILS,
SOME POWERFUL COOPERATION
COMMITTEE MIGHT ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO OVERCOME THE INITIAL DISLIKE
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY DISBELIEF
OF MICHAEL COHEN THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE AS A JUROR.
>> Laura: COLLUSION WITH THE
PRESIDENT?
IT'S INTERESTING BUT WE DON'T
KNOW COMPLETELY WHAT THEY HAVE.
WE DON'T KNOW.
CONGRESSMAN, I WANT TO TALK FOR
A MOMENT ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
TODAY WITH COMEY.
HE DOESN'T LIKE THIS IDEA OF
COMING IN AND TALKING TO YOU
GUYS IN CLOSED SESSION.
HE SENT OUT TWEETS.
"TODAY MY LEGAL TEAM FILED COURT
PAPERS TO TRY TO GET
TRANSPARENCY FROM HOUSE
REPUBLICANS.
LET THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WATCH."
HE SAID HE WAS NAUSEOUS, MAKES
ME NAUSEOUS.
THAT MADE ME NAUSEOUS TO SEE.
YOU ARE THE WANTS OF OUR PROBLEM
WITH TRANSPARENCY, THAT'S RICH,
COMING FROM COMEY.
>> IT'S NOT ABOUT TRANSPARENCY.
IT'S ABOUT STALL TACTICS.
THE INCOMING DEMOCRATIC CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE SAID, ACCORDING
TO BLOOMBERG TODAY THAT THIS IS
ABOUT TRYING TO POND IT OVER SO
THAT PERHAPS THE SUBPOENA CAN BV
THAT PERHAPS THE SUBPOENA CAN BR
THAT PERHAPS THE SUBPOENA CAN BE
THAT PERHAPS THE SUBPOENA CAN B.
THE REALITY IS THAT COMEY IS
FREE TO SAY WHATEVER STATEMENT
HE WANTS TO MAKE.
HE DOESN'T GET TO CHOOSE UNDER
WHICH FORUM CONGRESS CALLED HIM
FORWARD.
>> Laura: WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN NEXT?
>> HOPEFULLY THE COURT PROCESS
WILL WORK QUICKLY.
>> Laura: 5 MINUTES LEFT.
>> THERE WILL NOT BE AN
IMPEDIMENT TO THIS SUBPOENA,
FROM CONGRESS SHOULD BE A
SUBPOENA THAT STANDS IN ASIAN
TESTIFY.
>> Laura: SOL, INCOMING HOUSE
JUDICIARY CHAIR NADLER SAID
ANYONE WHO STILL BELIEVES THIS
IS A WITCH HUNT MUST NOW FACE
THE REALITY THAT THE
INVESTIGATION APPEARS TO BE
CLOSING IN ON THE PRESIDENT.
SOL, GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW NOW,
WHAT ABOUT THAT STATEMENT?
>> WELL, NUMBER ONE, I NEVER
THOUGHT IT WAS A WITCH HUNT.
THERE IS CERTAINLY NOTHING IN
THE OFFICIAL PAPERS THAT HAVE
BEEN RELEASED THAT WE LOOK AT
WHICH IS HOW MUELLER EXPLAINS
THINGS TO PEOPLE, THAT WOULD
INDICATE THAT THEY ARE CLOSING
IN ON THE PRESIDENT.
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE ANOTHER
POINT ABOUT COHEN.
COHEN'S CASE HAS ALREADY BEEN --
THE MUELLER CASE HAS ALREADY
BEEN REASSIGNED TO THE NEW YORK
JUDGE WHO HANDLED HIS ORIGINAL
CASE.
THE SENTENCING RANGE IN THIS
CASE IN NEW YORK WAS WITH THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT, 46 TO 57
MONTHS.
COULD BE AS HIGH AS 63 MONTHS.
BY CONSOLIDATING THESE FOR
SENTENCING, HE HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO GET PROBATION.
MUELLER IS GIVING HIM A 5K1 FOR
COOPERATION.
THEY ARE CONSOLIDATED FOR
SENTENCING.
THE JUDGE IN THE NEW YORK CASE
IN THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT CASE
WILL SENTENCE TOGETHER, THERE'S
A WHOLE GROUPING CONCEPT IN THE
GUIDELINES AT THE END OF THE DAY
CAN SAY YOUR COOPERATION WITH
MUELLER WAS SO GREAT, YOU ARE
GOING ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
PROBATION.
HIS ATTORNEYS COULD ARGUE FOR
THAT ANYWAY BUT WHEN YOU HAVE A
5K1 FROM THE GOVERNMENT, IT'S A
HUGE THING.